Very little is currently known about what's
going down in Ghostbusters 2020, but the cast,
the early teasers and the franchise's enduring
legacy are more than enough to get excited
about.
Here's what's in store.
Unusual for a project of such size, things
came together very quickly for Ghostbusters
2020.
In January 2019, the first reports of Jason
Reitman's involvement in a new Ghostbusters
film hit the headlines, followed the very
next day by a heavily nostalgic teaser trailer
for the movie.
Then, before the end of the month, fans had
a release date to look forward to.
Reitman confirmed via his Twitter account
that the film will hit theaters July 10th
2020, right in the prime of the summer movie
release season.
Reitman has noted that the idea for his Ghostbusters
project began with the image of a 12-year-old
girl carrying a proton pack, and that image
ultimately expanded to include a whole family.
Now, as the film draws closer, we're getting
a sense of what that family looks like - thanks
to its all-star cast.
The 12-year-old in question will be played
by Mckenna Grace, a rising young talent who's
appeared in everything from Captain Marvel
to the Chilling Adventures of Sabrina to I,
Tonya - and that's just in the last couple
of years.
Presumably playing Grace's mother in the film
is Carrie Coon, who has appeared in TV series
such as Fargo and The Leftovers as well as
films such as Gone Girl and Avengers: Infinity
War.
To play Coon's son, Grace's character's probable
brother, the film went with Finn Wolfhard,
best known to fans for his work as Mike Wheeler
on Stranger Things, as well as Richie Tozier
in the It movies.
Finally, in June, word got out that comedy
superstar-turned-superhero Paul Rudd had also
joined the cast in the role of a teacher.
So, a new cast is firmly in place for Ghostbusters
2020, but what about the cast of the original
film?
Well, this is where things get a little fuzzy.
Back in June, Sigourney Weaver seemed to confirm
in an interview that she was indeed reprising
her role as Dana Barrett.
Apparently referring to co-stars Bill Murray
and Dan Ayrkroyd, she said:
"It's going to be crazy working with the guys
again."
In the days following that report, Reitman
appeared at Ghostbusters Fan Fest and, rather
than confirming that the old stars would be
in the new movie, simply said that Weaver,
Murray, Ayrkroyd, and fellow co-star Ernie
Hudson had all read through the script.
“If there’s a steady paycheck in it I’ll
believe anything you say.”
Odds are this does mean that the original
cast will come back in some form for the film,
particularly since everyone from Murray to
Annie Potts has expressed an interest in returning.
"I love this plan!
I’m excited to be a part of it!
Let’s do it!”
“This job is definitely not worth another
five a year!”
Jason Reitman's feature film directorial career
began in 2005 with the release of his debut
film, Thank You For Smoking.
Since then he's become known for a particular
style that often walks the line between comedy
and drama, as seen in films like Juno, Up
in the Air, Tully, Young Adult, and most recently
The Front Runner.
His films are often small in scale, more devoted
to exploring the intimacy and absurdity of
human relationships than big setpieces, and
his comedy usually evolves out of interactions
between characters rather than any deliberate
attempts to set up jokes and gags.
"Did you see that comin’ when she sat us
down here?”
“Yeah, but I was hopin’ she was expelled
or into hard drugs.”
“That was my first instinct, too.
Or a DWI, anything but this."
Though he's undoubtedly formed his own writing
and directing style over the years, Reitman's
interest in filmmaking has its roots in family.
He is the son of actress Genevieve Robert
[and writer/director Ivan Reitman,
who's best known for his films Stripes, Kindergarten
Cop, and yes, Ghostbusters and Ghostbusters
II.
The Ghostbusters franchise is woven into the
fabric of Reitman's life, so much so that
he even had a cameo in the second film back
in 1989.
"You know, my dad says you guys are full of
crap.”
“Jason!”
“Well, some people have trouble believing
in the paranormal.”
“No, he just says you guys are full of crap
and that’s why you went out of business."
Very little has been shown of Ghostbusters
2020, but what has been released has consistently
leaned heavily on nostalgia.
The first teaser, which arrived in January
2019, sets the scene spookily enough with
plenty of crazy lighting and strange goings-on,
before the welcome appearance of a familiar
friend.
But apart from that teaser, all anyone has
to go on right now are a pair of photos Reitman
posted to his Instagram account from the set.
One introduced fans to the new family at the
heart of the film, with Coon, Grace, and Wolfhard
joined by the two generations of Ghostbusters
directors.
In the other, Reitman offered another look
at the ECTO-1, this time simply a close-up
of its wheel.
Despite all the hype surrounding Ghostbusters
2020, very little is known about the film's
story.
When Reitman's new take on Ghostbusters was
first announced, it was reported that the
film would be a continuation of the original
series, which would make it a direct, years-later
sequel to 1989's Ghostbusters II, ignoring
the controversial 2016 reboot.
So, that means a world in which Peter Venkman,
Ray Stantz, Egon Spengler, and Winston Zeddemore
successfully saved New York from ghosts on
more than one occasion.
Thanks to Reitman himself, it also seems clear
that the new story will center on family.
Exact details about the movie's supporting
cast, villains, ghosts and actual plot, however,
are still a mystery - and only time will tell
whether Reitman's movie will deliver the Ghostbusters
fans have been waiting for for over 30 years.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.